und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt Werner
Henning Landrat aus Eichsfeld einen
schönen guten Abend ihre Bilanz ist also
positiv was genau hat denn die Karte aus
ihrer Sicht
gebracht an die Karte verbinden sich
sehr viele Hoffnungen einige davon haben
sie genannt meine persönliche ist
gewesen und ist es nach wie vor zu
signalisieren an die Flüchtlinge nehmt
euer Leben selbst in die Hand sucht euch
Arbeit und wenn ihr diesen Weg geht dann
unterstützen wir nach Kräften und wir
privilegieren euch auch weiterhin mit
dem Erhalt von Bargeld denn wer sich
Arbeit sucht und wir wenigstens
teilweise mit zu seinem Lebensunterhalt
und dem seiner Familie beiträgt der soll
auch weiterhin zu 100% seine Leistungen
von uns in bar bekommen alle anderen in
etwa die Hälfte auf die Bezahlkarte und
genau
dieser Effekt spielt eine große Rolle in
dem 17 Flüchtling sofort Arbeit gesucht
haben und 35 andere sind in ihre
Heimatländer zurückgereist das werde ich
insgesamt erst einmal als einen
positiven auftagt das ist ja gerade ganz
offen ausgesprochen worden auch in dem
Beitrag den auch sie gerade gesehen
gehört haben
da hat der Kollege aus Eisfeld gesagt
aus Serbien nordmazedonien man habe das
Z Kenntnis genommen und sei dann
gegangen ist das etwas dass sie so
erwartet haben
auch in dieser Form nicht äh äh meine
Handlung resultiert überhaupt aus der
Not heraus weil ich nicht mehr in der
Lage bin die Flüchtlinge so
unterzubringen wie man dieses eben auch
müsste einfach weil die kapazitätten
nicht mehr vorhanden sind dadurch sind
wir getrieben worden eben dieses Signal
in Richtung Flüchtlinge zu geben aber
dass es so ausfällt habe ich mir am
Anfang auch so nicht vorgestellt freue
mich aber darüber ich erinnere mich
daran dass D in den Gesprächen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten es auch immer viel
darum geht dass er wahnsinnig
kompliziert so eine Karte einzuführen
das sei wahnsinnig viel Bürokratie und
hohe Kosten die daran hingen stimmt das
war es
kompliziert wir haben uns sehr viele
Anbieter bedient wir haben eine
öffentliche Ausschreibung veranstaltet
und aus meiner Sicht ist das ganze wie
man hier sagt kein
Hexenberg so kompliziert war es nicht
und wir haben dann sie haben die Karte
ja gezeigt uns eines Angebotes eben
bedient dieses angenommen im übrigen
nutze ich dieses Angebot schon seit über
einem Jahr für meine Mitarbeiter in der
Verwaltung alle angestellten Mitarbeiter
besitzen eine solche Karte und bekommen
bestimmte Leistungen auch als
Sachleistungen aber aus ganz anderen
Gründen das hat etwas mit Tarifvertrag
zu tun auf die Karte und es gibt
überhaupt keine Klagen und der Gedanke
war eben was für für die eigenen
Mitarbeiter gut ist wird auch für die
Flüchtlinge nicht schlecht sein der
Flüchtlingsrat das haben wir auch eben
gehört kritisiert das dass z.B an
einigen Stellen äh die Karte gar nicht
dann genommen werden kann muss da wenn
sie jetzt auch z.B an eine bundesweite
Einführungen ähm denken an welchen
Stellen muss noch nachgebessert
werden also zunächst äh hat unsere Karte
ein sehr breites Verteilnetz in der
ganzen Umgebung äh die Karte soll ja
geeignet sein um Sachleistungen im
täglichen Handel zu beziehen ich denke
dass alles dort mit zu bekommen ist aber
diese Karte hat nie den Anspruch gehabt
dass sie ein All Inclusive Paket ist
dass sie alle Wünsche rund um bedient
das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck
dieser Unternehmung und ich bin sicher
die Flüchtlinge werden sich selbst eben
auch
orientieren wo man diese Karte dann
konkret wie einsetzen kann äh da
vertraue ich drauf und höre bis heute
eben auch keine Klagen und ich bin eben
auch froh darüber dass wir diese Karte
in einer Eigendynamik begonnen haben
denn sonst wären uns all die Bedenken
schon vorausgeeilt die jetzt im Nachgang
ein Stückchen ja zu hören sind also
diese Bedenken vom Flüchtlingsrat kann
ich im letzten inhaltlich nicht teilen
obgleich ich Respekt habe vor den
Wortmeldungen eben doch des
Flüchtlingsrates aber wenn wir auf diese
Dinge Allam drück nehmen würden würden
wir überhaupt nicht weiterkommen herr
Henning vielleicht noch ganz kurz sie
sind in Thüringen da ist die AFD sehr
stark Migration auch die Ausnutzung von
Sozialsystem ist ja ein klassisches
Thema der AFD haben Sie das Gefühl also
nein ich frage mal so was was ist die
Reaktion von
denen ich befasse mich überhaupt nicht
mit den politischen Reaktionen also mein
meine Kommunikationspartner oder
Gesprächspartner sind jetzt in dieser
Situation nicht die Partei sondern ich
verwalte hier
Aufgaben ich bin für Dinge zuständig ich
bin bemüht nach besten Wissen und
Gewissen meiner Verantwortung gerecht zu
werden aber was ich insgesamt in der
Bevölkerung wahrnehme ist sehr viel
Zustimmung und positive Haltung
politische Kritik habe ich bisher von
keiner Seite vernommen und einen Dialog
mit der AFD führe ich auch nicht das
sagt Werner Henning Landrat aus Eichfeld
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für das
Gespräch heute Abend
bittte schön